We know that we need to multiply 3.1 by 10, 21 times. So that means we need to
move this decimal point to the right 21 times. Let's do it. Okay. I'm going to
start with our number we have originally, 3.1, and let's get ready to move.
Okay, count with me. One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen, sixteen, seventeen, eighteen,
nineteen, twenty, and twenty one. well that was a lot of work. The exponent is
21, and I just verified there are in fact 21 loops here. We know that each of
these empty ones needs a 0 in it. So let me write those in. There we go, this
is our final number. We've moved the decimal point all the way out here. Turns
out 3.1 times 10 to the 21. Is a pretty big number.